I am a metastatic breast cancer to the bones of January, February, went off all my meds.
My alcohol and phosphatase, this is a liver function test, but
remember, alcohol and phosphatase also will go off if there's, if there's
bony destruction. So if there's bony destruction for metastatic cancer to the bone, which
remember, I said multiple times that almost all metastatic cancer to the bone is
lytic in nature, mediates destroyed bone, and the alcohol and phosphatase will rise. So this
is a good, this is a good marker to use for if there's any increase in bony destruction.
So this went down, so that's really good. So my calcium went from 9 to 9.3, but that's not much,
that's not enough of a difference to say that there's lab error there. So I would say that's really
the same. So you're still with a normal range there. So that's fine. Your AST went from 22 to 36.
That really AST really has nothing to do with bony destruction. So AST has to do with,
it's a liver enzyme has to do with some liver function or there's, it could be simply because
detoxing the different meds, that's literally what it could be for metastatic cancer. There's lots of
different things that could, that could cause that rise. But even at that, I wouldn't be concerned
and since you're, you're going to take, you're going to do these blood work monthly. Let's just
keep an eye on it. And again, with all blood work, remember, you're looking for patterns. So
what is the pattern? How does it change? Is it going in the right directions or is it going
in the wrong directions over time? That's good.